[Music]
keep that in there you're listening to
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum
Ryan just hit his leg pretty hard and I
use he's the word F I use the I used the
f-bomb these are F word so have it Hey
Dude how was your weekend Jesus you seem
you seem frustrated you seem tired you
don't look you look good but I think you
I know you had a thing that rhymes with
Uri duty I get yeah I got I got nabbed
for jury duty last couple weeks so we've
had to reschedule a couple recordings we
have sorry about that it's not your
fault man we had snot it's pain in the
ass did they pay you for that no nothing
you get paid not much like 20 bucks a
day maybe they reimburse you for some
miles all right I'll tell you all about
it when it's all done but it's not quite
done so I'm sorry to hear that it's all
right but I hope you guys like the first
episode because Ryan kicked some royal
ass I mean you did man the Brandon Ralph
episode great for a first week I think
you know the numbers killed we want to
increase those numbers so we do ask you
man please we just were bringing you
video you could watch them on YouTube
you could still listen to them on all
the platforms but Ryan's hard work it
doesn't go unnoticed especially to me
and I think the viewers are really
loving it so going to YouTube subscribe
hit the bell so the notifications it
notifies you when to uh your youtubing
yeah well that's the way to do it you
know that's the way to do it yeah
subscribe on youtube to catch every
great moment it inside of you on video
now which is really exciting I'm very
happy with the video you're kicking ass
and this episode is fantastic and you
know as great as Jess I see her just
laughing so loudly and like enjoying
herself when she's like reviewing them
before they go to air and you know Bryce
has got a kid gets kick out of it who
does the social and really helps us out
here um
so I'm glad you guys like it please
spread the word share the video links
you know we want to start yeah we want
to just get going here and get some big
numbers and get some advertisers and you
know get paid I guess tomorrow night is
Wednesday night and left on Laurel my
band we you know we are getting back
together we don't play often
but we're getting together Wednesday at
7:00 p.m. tomorrow night and we're gonna
play a stage it so go to stage it calm
or wherever and you can go in there and
watch us do a little live show so Lee's
film of Kent and Tom Wiley and Danson
and Carl McDowell from ballers you know
Carl
he's the bassist so I remember you
listen to the songs in the beginning a
couple of them we played for yeah like I
got a big old LP you do in my apartment
that stood ya frame that Center
merriment yeah you got a frame it you're
not framing [ __ ]
so anyway they'll be prizes tomorrow
night and all that I also want to shout
out to patreon all all my patrons if you
love the podcast you more support in
other ways and you're like I don't need
a dollar a month or whatever it is
there's tears there you can go to inside
of you on the patreon you can see who
the upcoming guests are and for if
you're on a certainty or ask questions
for certain guests there's extra footage
bonus EPS with me and friends inside of
me where you ask me questions on video
merch packages for certain tiers there's
a whole bunch of stuff and I'm having a
good time with it I randomly just start
texting people and it's like a little
community and so that's cool
so patreon if you feel ever so what's
the word inclined inclined good work
good word March 31st at the north door
in Austin Texas I'm interviewing exactly
by the first show is sold out at the
North or the 7:30 show but there's still
some tickets for the later show with me
and Zach so exactly vises am Chuck all
that stuff March 31st at the North
Aurora in Austin
I'll be leaving New Mexico this week
Ryan that's exciting I'm excited for
yeah it'll be fun man you know the whole
thing with the corona virus and you know
it's everywhere you know with people are
trying to instill fear and I'm just
gonna be careful and you know I wash
your hands does that okey that's it
that's all wash your hands you tuck you
face left I pick my nose I shouldn't do
that I like but I think everyone is now
realizing how much we all actually touch
our faces on a like a mid by minute
basis it's a lot maybe I shouldn't pick
my nose anymore maybe this will stop me
something I do in kids but I mean we
can't prevent it
oh so Mexico we're coming to you la mole
a for four days doing Smallville nights
Tom Welling and I also quickly in Miami
I'll be doing a con May ninth I'll be
there for the weekend Tom Welling and I
were doing Smallville nights in Miami
they're also doing st. Louis Wizard
World on June 5th and the Smallville
Knights if you haven't seen it you're in
for a treat
the one we just did in Richmond was off
the off the chain man
use that lightly either no I didn't and
oh I just want to say one more thing uh
I think Ryan I might have told you about
this but I I've been to these adult
summer camps so I've decided I've always
wanted one my friends have always said
dude this is you well I don't I mean
they don't even think of me like you you
should be in a big movies you should own
your you should have your own summer
camp so I bought the rights for a summer
camp that I created called camp Rosie
and my buddy is working with me and we
are going to throw a adult summer camp
an hour north of Los Angeles or you know
where I live and it is going to be
Halloween so two nights two full days
all your meals included bedding you're
in a cabin you got your bunk it's a
community all your meals you even get
gluten free stuff it's gonna be
incredible we had crazy DJ's at Friday
night 80s party whenever Saturday
Halloween a costume party both are
costume parties it is the most fun
you'll ever have it really is cuz I've
gone five years in a row but I've always
wanted to do my own so I'm breaking away
and I'm doing it so tickets will come up
soon I'm just giving you a little you
know tweet me Instagram me message me
whatever and and if you're interested
let me know it is going to be fantastic
and the prices and all that stuff will
be coming up an event bright soon and if
you keep listening you'll get a discount
something off your ticket if you buy
early so camp rosie is coming around the
corner that's coming that's about a lot
to say
make sure you donate if you're gonna
donate any money to anything maybe
Ronald McDonald House of Los Angeles or
anywhere around there they're all over
the world food on foot echoes of hope
for foster youth who don't fit for
homeless great organizations helping
people and I can't thank you enough
stick stick around after because after
this beautiful interview I'm going to
read some of the shoutouts for patreon
talk about a couple other things and
so this this guess was pretty cool this
was this is a good one
he got deep - man I love when people get
deep and he really talked about his dad
yeah it was really good because he got a
little emotional you could tell there
was it there of those moments yeah did
you zoom in on that moment zoom in would
that be weird if Hopkins eyes look
there's a T though just hated some tears
on him people get emotional I get a
little emotional and this guy is
wonderful we worked years two years ago
together on a short film he broke out
and did a bunch of stuff I went my own
way and he became a big hit on the show
called Silicon Valley funny as hell you
know I'm the bearded guy he's brilliant
I love him I consider him a friend he
plays football with me on occasion only
played once eight years ago but without
further ado let's get inside of Martin
Starr it's my part of you you're
listening to inside of you with Michael
Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you'll never know which is what how's
everything going man haven't seen you in
a long time I want to save it I really
wanted to give you a hug at least and
that was nice that's good you know it's
going it's going really well
it's going better than I thought it
would go okay still at life in general
lately you still got your looks I don't
know about that I just had some laser
treatment on my cancerous spots I
thought you were gonna say something
else
Oh my wiener I don't know dude people do
laser for all the wrong reasons in the
city have you ever had anything lasered
off your genitals no but had a scary
pimple once on your genitals it was not
in a visible area and I can see my
entire genitals
was it above the for lack of a better
term nutsack nope wasn't below between
that and the you know that other area
it's a soft sell song the tainted love
do you say is that what it was
yeah that's obviously not a disease no
sorry no disease wasn't involved it was
painful and then it never happened again
this is oil how was young no no last I
think they do I thought I had to boil my
nose once I did have a boil my nose I
doing the filming of the show you boil
it off
they took myself out I'm sure this is
the end of the interview now yeah that's
it when we're getting the boils and
genitals and which and what haven't you
well they just put a needle in it was
the most painful thing imagine like
gripping something almost to the point
where it's like clay and then you're
actually gripping wood you're almost
melting you're almost going through that
with your hands the wood because you're
it's in somewhat you're bracing on for
your breath like hair well I was on a
table but I had there was these little
metal levers and I remember just it was
like okay this is gonna hurt but through
your nose a lot of nerves like a zit on
your nose like the worst worst it's in
that spot yeah it's Teddy he was like
going a needle needle needle I'm just
going that's face you make I guess
you're gonna see my face cuz
I was everything I took in I don't want
to move that much I don't know what the
situation was Boyle removal yeah I
wasn't a removal was more like a let's
get the inflammation down I'll never do
that again I'd rather have a Peter Boyle
on my nose and act it out yeah
then go through that again but the other
Boyle who is that woman who's a great
singer but Susan Boyle Susan Ballou
Susan Boyle what happened to her I mean
the real question is what happ what
happened or no sorry no it's all in how
you say it well really she was nobody
and then she became somebody so it
wasn't what happened to her Oh see I
guess it is what happened to hers and
she rose so fast and then what happened
to her oh she had such a good life and
then what happened to her what happened
we ruined their do we say that to each
other instantly Hollywood it's like what
happened to Martin Starr what do you
mean him on Silicon Valley but what
happened not anymore now it's gonna be
what happened to have the ol aired yet
oh yeah we're done season six when are
you gonna air this in the past just
accordingly no we know it's I'm kidding
okay
baby I gotta watch it come and go on
back to the genitalia
wait I'm kidding we're not gonna go
there have you seen when's the last time
you saw Elizabeth Ellen that's right
okay let's get into that so all right so
so uh so you and I met on the set I
don't know here what's break it down for
the visual yes we for our viewers so
here's what happened yeah we met on a
short called eyeball Eddie mhm and it
was about a kid with a glass eye that
was your first acting performance in
film I guess you could say right yeah
yeah yeah yeah I I grew up out here so I
did things here and there but that was
the first thing that I got to like that
and then the pilot for Freaks and Geeks
happened right around the same time
right at the pilot became famous pretty
quickly and then oh yeah everyone saw
everyone saw freezin gates 20 years late
it's probably the biggest cult thing
that ever happened and I did more for
your career but probably over the last
uh you know what in some ways and I
think in other ways it would have been
maybe detrimental if the only thing I
had done like if seven years later eight
years later the only thing that I had
done was that
I it would have been much harder to
break out of that you know it's good
news is that if they said you weren't a
dick probably on set because Judd Apatow
started casting you so you didn't really
know what Judd Apatow was gonna do other
than Freaks and Geeks he hadn't really
done much other they produced a lot I
mean but he actually been a part of a
lot of great things like what I'm not
saying he's in Stiller show
I mean his his producing resume is
massive but I'm talking about like he
blew up after Freaks and Geeks I'm him
knocked up all these other movies that
came out it just I think was really
knocked up that said it our four year
old virgin right that was first told ero
version was version the 40-year old
version of four year old virgin diya
which comes out in 27 years that that
movie I think really exploded his
people's awareness of him yeah you were
a nice guy in the said he liked you
obviously there was probably some people
on set that were a little trouble that
didn't work as much maybe who I was
trouble you are you're a pain in the ass
they're all trouble do you think he
didn't like if you could get kids but
one person you didn't like one person
Apatow didn't like on that set if you
had to think about it it wasn't James
Franco what does that man well because
he put him in a lot of stuff didn't he
yeah I know but I don't know that that I
also don't know that that necessarily
dictates the way people people's working
relationships work weirdly I I always
find it confusing when you meet someone
who and I'm not gonna get into a name
game on this but when you meet people
who are who are difficult and they and
their careers aren't hurting because of
that does that make sense
I think this is a business where and
perhaps any business where you really
saw it after it just kind of depends on
the individual and people will kind of
take what they can business-wise and
suffer the consequences in other Wow
you just said something that I really
didn't think was the case it's less now
than it used to right but if someone's
difficult on set in the end the director
of the producer the creator doesn't
really like them but they blow up he's
going like well we have relationship I'm
gonna put them in something else see if
he does it is valuable the people have
value in foreign markets and if you can
get a movie made because you've got
somebody in it you'd take a hit sometime
I suppose those aren't decisions that
I've made so I I don't really I can't
speak to it on my own behalf but I just
watch it happen right all right before
we get into some stuff I want to go back
I want to go back before you start
because obviously you've got a great
career I mean hey party Dalian lots of
movies oh that's that's so great it's
all but that's not as the point of this
podcast I did not tell you all right and
listen to it it's fine you know and the
point really is is I don't you know if I
want I want to talk about your career
that weld inside of you inside of you of
micros mom at least you it's right
behind you it says that no it's behind
you but I feel like if you want to talk
about your career and just the things
you're doing and look at me a Martin
star and tell a quick funny witty story
you go on Fallon you go on whatever
which I don't but if people want to go I
don't want to see who Martin Starr is
and I think Rosenbaum and get to the
bottom of it without interrogating even
making is gonna get inside you know I
think you look it's always become
therapy for me this stuff's been therapy
for me and then it becomes sort of
therapy for everyone and hopefully you
get something at it and I think people
have a good time
I really it's good to reconnect with you
I love it and by the way although you I
knew you and you early you were kid
you're 10 years younger than yeah but I
was like I don't know how old I was I
was probably 25 yeah we were 15
those are incompatible ages right but
now we're not that far an age where
you're 38 um we've been through similar
things like I think at some point it
just levels off right like there's
there's the rise of growth and
development and all that you're learning
and at some point you kind of get the
way everything works mhm and then it's
it all fluctuates based on how much you
put into life really well I think you
have put a lot into life thanks because
many of your characters don't laugh
right yeah they're not big lappers
they're usually like I'm gonna throw
something out here in [ __ ] you
well that's what I did for the last six
years you didn't by the way I you know
did all they told it's all yeah I get to
do a lot of time in spider-man it's a
very like different character one quirky
yeah and that's fun to do it all were
you gonna say well I was gonna get back
to like you know your parents were
divorced right when I met you yeah that
right yeah they divorced when I was four
when you were four now that couldn't
have been like
it's price something you're dealing with
and you think oh it's fine everything's
fine but you probably have these things
that attach to you growing up that
you're like oh my parents are divorced
my dad's I don't know if it was a
divorce right they were both a big part
of my life they were yeah my mom had
custody for a short period of time
well she had folks she had one full
custody especially then I think it was
support the mother when it came to the
legal matters like that in a divorce the
the mother usually gets custody which is
probably still somewhat the case but I
would imagine now they kind of look at
everything at all the details where then
it probably should have been split
custody shared custody right but they
just were like the you know her lawyer
went in and fought hard and and a year
after she won sole custody she I think
recognized that I needed a father that I
needed my father just to be a part of my
life and so she didn't want to because
she was fighting with him and didn't
like him and they had a difficult
relationship she didn't want that to she
came to her senses in a way that was I
appreciate now so much that it could
have gone totally differently well
that's incredible that your mom's you
know because a lot of women or men
depending on who has custody would be
like [ __ ] that you're not to be with
that [ __ ] she did I don't care she
did that for a while yeah but what was
the turning point
I think the especially on a boy the
effects of not having your father like
you act out emotionally I'm sure at some
point she just saw that it was probably
having a negative effect that she could
see that was tangible and she made the
right decision do you think it was one
of those moments where you're like she
goes like I can't take this anymore
because you're just like [ __ ] you're
like you know what he needs to have so
many time with dad maybe he's flipping
out on me and I am taking all the brunt
of it
you did what did you fight it not until
I was older I don't think when you're
younger that's what happened you love
your parents they're the perfect person
nothing then you realize wait you're
[ __ ] too yeah well then they become
the opposite then they know nothing and
you know everything and at some point
you like figure out you hope such a mix
of yeah I still don't
they know anything are you print
illegally no no they they divorce
probably 17 years ago my mom is in her
third marriage my dad just divorced for
his second time but he was in the
marriage so they were together when her
27th when we shot I bought a I think
they got divorced cuz that was more than
17 years ago they were probably married
around then and it was really hard to me
because I remember my mother was calling
me and saying st. crazy she said crazy
[ __ ] we were going through a divorce and
she's hurt and I get up in like I can't
live anymore I don't want to live and
I'm like please don't kill yourself or
I'm on a show my first show ever I don't
want to get fired when I have Smallville
um was it small no I don't think they
got ya maybe it was Smallville was
Smallville I remember actually it was
the I remember the the room I was I was
staying at this apartment this little
studio apartment and I remember I was
started getting a little anxiety then
because it was I mean you I'm sure you
sensed it as a kid you saw the fighting
even though you
they separated when you were four right
yeah yeah but you still felt it right Oh
constantly well they were fighting with
each other through me for a for a while
because you feel that like they're there
now fighting each other and I'm in the
middle and they tried to avoid that but
I heard them fight all the time it was
that movie Kramer vs Kramer did you feel
like a Kramer vs Kramer kid I didn't see
that movie so I don't know well it's
just a tug of war and then you know I
think what was there was the other movie
irreconcilable difference is what was
the movie where the kid divorces the
parents Oh anyway it wasn't moving it
sounds like a comedy but were you just
but did you have that hope as a kid like
I wanted to get back together you think
there was did you ever think there was
any hope of a day like there's this is
never happening I never thought about it
cuz in conscious and in my consciousness
I never knew them to be together
like when you're four years olds life
hasn't really formed around you yet
you're still figuring out so much so I
knew that there were changes happening
but I couldn't put my finger on it until
I was much older and at that point I was
so accustomed to them being a part that
it didn't make sense for them to be
together yeah
and they fought so much like they
didn't get along well their drinking or
anything like that it was or as it
wasn't had anything to do with that I
just did get along yeah my did I know my
dad had a drinking problem before they
were married and maybe at the beginning
of their marriage but when I knew him he
didn't he would drink non-alcoholic beer
and loved it just loved he never saw him
lit for the most part no not until I was
older and then he like would drink a
little bit more but he never drank a lot
like he wouldn't he wouldn't he never
got like fall down drunk I never ever
had that experience that's good
did you hate like you know seeing your
mom dating guys as you get you were
getting older and you're like [ __ ] it's
not my dad this is were you just
rebellious no she went on a date with
Bill Cartwright once and I get a
Cartwright from the Bulls the basketball
player I came up to like probably the
bottom of his scrotum like I must have
been like nine years you see Royals no
no he was wearing pants I wasn't like
thank God I wasn't like that was that
mom and then he comes out I'm just like
whoa what are those hey sir
um he he was just in our house at some
point I know my mom went on a date with
him that was it I knew no details out on
that I just remember thinking oh that's
cool did he say hey do you like a man
you know one yeah super I was it hurt my
neck to look I'm sure he was very tall
and he was nice and were you like when
they didn't work out like what yeah I
did not I didn't think about it in those
terms she she her longest relationship
was in my teens and that went into my
20s with a guy named Frank Frank who we
all lived together at some point from
like 16 I moved out at 17 and then like
came back like when I was living there
when we didn't have already and there's
one night oh my god I can't imagine the
feeling do you remember that group of
kids cuz it was just a bunch of USC kids
yeah yeah Elizabeth Allen led the charge
but but all the producers and everyone
else they were all like pals from USC
making everyone's kind of short films
together I think as as that happens I
guess as you're going through film
school and I went to the party our wrap
party and I was
sixteen and I got I didn't know you
don't drink different alcohols together
no one showed me the ropes that was the
first time like I'd had alcohol before
but I was seventeen so this was like
your mixes beer and liquor it was on a
new level yeah there was like vodka in a
watermelon and I had some of that and
then I drank some like whiskey with some
[ __ ] in it and then a beer and I was
just like I could drink anything cut to
me laying down behind it I remember
putting my head down thinking that the
carpet was very comfortable laid down
out woke up in my bed the next day and
my mom said that she watched my limp
body get dragged in by the USC kids that
I was working with and they were so
apologetic that they had like and I
vomited in someone's car everyone told
me this I don't remember a moment of it
I felt like now I feel bad thinking back
to how much that must've they were
worried I was dead fully worried I was
dead bringing a dead body because she
was never drain my mother that much
before then not like that obviously and
I haven't gotten blacked out drunk of
many times in mouth so you have like
that after that yeah I'm blacking out
right now I am [ __ ] but but Frank was in
your life for a little while and
ultimately did you like him for whatever
I think he was a nice guy he really
tried his best I don't think he and my
mom are quite meant to work out but he
tried his best have like be helpful to
me and he saw ahead of the game I
remember he he was there when freaks and
geeks happened and he was like I bought
the domain Martin Starcom and as I go oh
cool and this was it was like just fun
anything right it was like not huge yet
and now all of it has evolved like if
now you it's not calm you want to get
your own app if you don't have your
Martin Starr app you know have you
arrived no he got it for me as like a
gift but it was just like he was just
kind of thoughtful and business minded
like that so he had thought that that
would be valuable I never ended up using
it so Frank you ever talked to Frank now
I haven't talked to him in a while but I
caught up with him once in New York
nice yeah I think he lost his wife to
cancer I think I met with him before
that happened but I know she was sick
when I saw him he's he's yeah he's a
nice guy
that's good it's not a lot of people
kids that could say that you know when
their mom dates some guys and you know
she goes you know it's not like she went
through a lot of man I'm just saying you
know then all of a sudden you're like
you know Franco I'll go meet with Franco
don't talk to him a lot but it's nice
that you had some kind of relationship
yeah I mean he was Drive your dad [ __ ]
crazy that was there for formative year
it's know my dad wasn't jealous like
that he was very thoughtful in that way
he'd be still with you right no my
father passed away when did that happen
just over five years ago uh he had ALS
and that was real difficult to witness
to like be a part of it in some ways
doesn't happen fast it happened it takes
it took him a while but it for a long
time it was time spent wondering what's
going on cuz his body just didn't make
sense to him anymore it he was he had
low energy like the the effects aren't
always tangible they're not visible like
you don't see all the side effects it's
hard to pinpoint exactly what the
problem is and so he came out I remember
at one point he came out to LA and this
is definitely when he was being affected
by ALS and he but he didn't know what it
was yet and now the doctors that he had
saw could even like get into that genre
of issue they just kind of tried to deal
with his energy issues so they just woke
up just hidden no energy I slept I can't
like I can't get through a day is every
day I think he felt zapped and and then
and it would aggravate him so then he
would spend energy angry and it also
makes you probably anxious and getting
anxiety going I'm anxious from being
tired yeah well of thinking I'm gonna be
too tired to accomplish the tasks or
whatever essentially als is like your
body's shutting down while you're still
in it and that was at the beginning of
Silicon Valley the success of Silicon
Valley right when he passed yeah it was
either the
first yeah the first year that we went
to the Emmys I didn't make it because I
was with him and and it and it was I
know it was there there was something
there's something there's something kind
of joyful because that experience meant
so much to me now and all of those
people that I got to work with means so
much to me that for my dad to kind of be
there at the beginning of it to kind of
to watch that rocket take off and
appreciate it kind of makes it even that
much more special to me yeah and in
particular I see the kumail came and did
your podcast he was great he was my dad
loved his character the most on the show
because in our because I think he had a
pretty accurate perception of it which
was that Kumail is the heart of the show
he's you know and and that might
fluctuate a bit but he always wore his
heart on his sleeve unlike a lot of the
other characters who were kind of being
conniving and or or who are closed
awfully closed off like the character I
played and your dad liked that about him
he had that character was it was
relatable it was he could connect you
can connect with someone who's open like
that yeah and he just really liked him
and appreciated you know how where that
comedy came from and you know where that
character came from I could see you get
like I could see getting emotional yeah
maybe you're wrong but I can just see
how much like you just like they could
see moments that you're going through in
your head of like the kya touch me and
I'm thinking I can just see you seeing
your dad and how he reacted I could just
like oh that was going through your eyes
it's crazy but um you know it's nice
that you a lot of people don't have that
that experience of you know when they
lose someone tragically or whatever but
you feel like he got to see your success
he got to see all these things you have
these great memories you have that he
was always a good father he was there
even though they were divorced I mean
that's kind of a that's rare right yeah
it's I don't I guess I don't know how
rare it is because I only have my own
experiences but
it's really a as I I don't take it for
granted yeah I feel really lucky he was
I mean he was very much like that he
wore his heart on his sleeve in a lot of
ways and really tried to do it more and
more the older he got but he made a lot
of mistakes when he was younger - and I
think Eve tried to recognize those and
make not make them again which is really
the best thing you can hope for in a
life because we're all gonna make
mistakes and some of those are pretty
tough - to recognize and deal with but
if you do your best not to continue that
cycle once you're aware of it I mean
it's so hard - yeah it can be very
difficult I mean you know to me that's
you know whatever happened you as a kid
you're like oh I'm not gonna do that or
if I wasn't loved a certain way I'm
gonna love more and he did that that was
one of the things actually I think he
did pretty well because I don't think he
felt a lot of love from his parents and
he also [ __ ] up with [ __ ] up like he
had been through a marriage before my
mother then they divorced and he got
married again
and in his first marriage I don't think
he really knew how to love and he was
figuring that out and had a lot of anger
issues but by the time he had me he had
figured out what you know how to be a
parent at least a bit more and his dad I
don't think was super present and ended
up leaving his family to go start a new
family at some point and just like fully
left for the band for kids yeah but that
was when he was I think when he was
older so it it still happened like you
still deal with it but you're like fully
formed as a human being and then you're
like wait a sec where did my dad go and
he's just with a new family he was for
me anyway
he was very present III had a very
fortunate experience with him and I know
that my half siblings from his first
marriage didn't have the same experience
and it and there are times where I feel
guilty yeah and it pains me that we
don't all kind of share the same
experience and the same type of love for
him
have they ever reached out or do the
people reach out oh yeah we're we're
pretty close yeah you are
yeah my brother and I while we are
fairly kind of different people and in
some ways it makes it I don't know it's
more that there's distance you know he
lives in DC and I live out here so we
don't see each other too often but he is
a huge heart and we try and stay
connected as much as we can but it makes
it hard with the distance my two sisters
Annie and Carrie they both live up in
near Portland in in Vancouver Washington
you visit every once in a while really
sweet yeah Carrie and I have stayed the
closest Carrie not she's she's just a
[ __ ] awesome lady yeah I'm like there
are those times I'm sure you feel this
way I feel like this is as part of the
human experience where you look around
you and you're like wow I'm so lucky I'm
lucky that I I'm lucky that I had a dad
who at least by the time he had me he
kind of figured it out somewhat and I
had a really good connection with him
I'm lucky that with him came a great
brother and this [ __ ] awesome sister
and another sister who probably
struggles and like is trying to figure
[ __ ] out but to have like Carrie in my
life is so incredible that's being
grateful yeah that's you know they
always say the best thing you could do
for your health is just be grateful be
genuinely grateful so he's saying these
things it's just like it's it to me it
it does make sense I don't know many
times people have said just wake up say
things you're grateful for before you go
to sleep say the things you're grateful
for
isn't it weird the thing that you'd like
people need a reminder and maybe and I'm
sure I do too a fair amount of times but
it is kind of an interesting thing that
it doesn't that it doesn't come as
naturally as it should
well I mean even I wasn't gonna say this
because it's you know this one this air
is this will be a little time but you
know the Kobe Bryant's passing right
yeah I think you know it's weird because
you know when Bowie passed was like oh
they the Bowie legend and all these
other people but you know people in
their 60s or 70s or whatever they've had
and for some reason maybe because I you
know I met him I've seen him put it was
just
he's a 40 year old guy there's a 13 year
old daughter and it the thing that hit
me most is which is true nothing matters
except connection and love nothing like
nothing and people forget my point is is
we just say yeah yeah I love everybody
and we're in the moment and everybody's
instagramming and tweeting each other
right and they're like it doesn't matter
if you have five hundred million in the
bank and you have you know all this Fame
and you could live wherever you want
travel or you ever want it it doesn't
mean [ __ ] yeah I mean none of that
matters because now he's gone yeah right
but it seems like the the interesting
thing which I didn't realize until now
seeing all these clips of him is that he
really seemed to live a full life
it was just paying it forward yes he was
it was he was helping so many people and
then present in so many people's lives
in a way that was intimate and and
considerate and an altruist down
superficial yeah yeah what a beautiful
lesson to learn and then his time just
we don't know and we could always just
say it when something tragic happens to
stay close to your loved ones yeah and
call your mother call your this you
can't live in perpetual I love you this
is the last time yeah but you could be
more aware yeah it could be more aware
of the people you're talking to and
appreciate them more I Ryan I appreciate
you you know and so that you know when I
think of that you know and I think your
dad and I think of like you know being
present being in those moments and
having those moments and it's really
that's all we have our moments that's it
at the end of the day doesn't matter
when you die you have done all these
credits and what does that mean now
doesn't mean anything you you know right
mm-hmm
I don't know thanks for getting deep
with me for a second oh can I share two
stories with you but my dad I'd love it
they're just kind of two things that I
think embody who he wanted to be all the
time but we're all while he was so he
was so sick when he was his sega's that
his legs were as thin as my arms and I
could see when he came and picked me
up at the airport came to pick me up in
a car and he was driving and his legs
were so thin and frail that it didn't
make sense to me that his body was
capable of moving the car pushing the
pedal down but he acted as if nothing
was wrong because it was really the
first time I had seen him since this had
really hit did he acknowledge it did you
acknowledge him I say yeah I said your
dick probably looks massive what'd he
say come on are we laughs yeah this is
absolutely he taught me this sense of
humor so his body is so frail and in the
coming months it got worse and it became
difficult to put his own clothes on and
and things like that and there was a day
when I think he realized that pretty
soon he there was no way he was really
gonna be able to move himself in the way
that he's become accustomed and so he
got up before his wife before my stepmom
and and got in the car she didn't know
what was going on it didn't make sense
like she always kind of helps him get
dressed and stuff at this point and so
she so he just kind of snuck out got in
the car went to Starbucks to get her
coffee because she loves coffee in the
morning and not any knew how much it
kind of means to her and just a simple
thing so the simple gesture of love is
is his motive and he gets up and he goes
to Starbucks and they have drive-through
windows that is in Florida and so he
goes to the drive-through orders and
when he gets to the window his arms are
so weak that these two giant cups of
coffee he can only move one at a time so
he like grabs one like the guy hands him
two cups cuff and he's like yeah yeah
just grab the one here put that down and
grab the other one that guy's like holy
[ __ ] like is that like the looks he got
from this guy we're insane and he was
like are you alright but should you be
driving and then so he brings the coffee
home gets out of the car sets the coffee
in and she wakes up to two cups of
coffee
which he had to painstakingly go through
so much effort for and that was probably
a small gesture for him to show
I'm his a huge gesture in some ways but
for him to just show that he probably
didn't pay enough attention and that's
you know he expressed that to me later
but that really he was he was just like
there are so many times I didn't do the
smallest things that if I could go back
knowing what I know now I would have
done so much more so that's the sad
that's a sense that's a like I mean it's
sorry the whole story but you know it's
like but it's a yeah it's like I could
have done all these things into that in
that moment that was the hardest thing
he could have done any good or not yeah
that was the hardest thing and he wanted
to do that to show her some more so love
love love showing as much love as his
body was capable in that experience and
I think that's we're talking about it so
people do pass away they did some
science they did some research about
like you know what mistakes did you make
her what would you change
I wouldn't work so much I'd love more I
yeah I did they're all these things that
they would do and it's always the same
thing but it's hard to make someone in
the moment as a young man or whatever
going through all these things going
yeah but that's but you should pay
attention to those people because that's
you in however many years so do what you
can now and it's hard but I think if you
get the routine of just changing what
you do and by the way it makes you feel
good it does there's nothing better than
being grateful there's nothing better
than doing other an act of kindness for
someone else there's nothing much more
weight feeling yeah I never knew that I
mean I always felt like I was a good
good guy but then once I started doing
hands-on things you're like I mean
that's what it's about
that's it that's that's what's gonna
make you feel good it's not gonna be
like a residual check or a job that is
what's gonna make you feel good yeah
easily one of the most rewarding things
I do each year that I can make it is
charity in Kansas City what's that
called it's called big slick it's for
the Children's Hospital Mercy Children's
House
but our Children's Mercy Hospital in
Kansas City and it's going to visit the
hospital is easily the most rewarding
hour of my year well if you ever want to
go the Ronald McDonald House with me in
Los Angeles I got to go every other
Tuesday yeah yeah yeah
yeah so you love to yeah I'd love for
you to go yeah I'm serious
yeah I'm in oh I'll text you that's the
other story this'll be a bit lighter
hearted
I like the dick joke and Donna yeah
that's a good it's in that pain um no
pun intended he so it was at a point
where he was he couldn't go all the way
to the bathroom so I became like the
[ __ ] remover of his portable toilet that
we had in the living room
and he would sit in the living room and
chant I was raised Buddhist and so he
would sit in chant nam-myoho-renge-kyo
to his altar in a very hushed tone
because that's all he really could get
out because his lungs like ALS kind of
affects the body and such a severe way
what's the chant nam-myoho-renge-kyo
loudly those are the words but he says
it loudly he's chanting he's saying it's
awful softly yeah because he can't
really get the words out okay okay when
you're in a room full of people doing it
that's when in unison that's when it's
very gotcha there's a resonance to it
that's powerful and he had a very
powerful voice when he would say that
because he wasted so many words he was a
Salesman he was saying this is my Karma
for wasting so many words that my voice
is taken away and so he was in the
living room chanting and he was like oh
I gotta take a [ __ ] and so he moves
three feet to get on the portable toilet
and and sits there takes a [ __ ] and he's
taking a [ __ ] I walked into the room and
he just looks over his shoulder at me
and he says this is why I don't get
invited to parties anymore and that was
it he never lost this at the humor which
is you can't drag him inside of you is
supported by better help online
counseling I love this stuff if you
listen to the podcast you know I love it
better help you know cuz Ryan my life is
stressful I know yours can be stressful
oh yeah editing these shows is stressful
isn't it it can be stressful jury do
is stressful duty is stressful and if
you need help if you need to talk to
someone which I encourage people talk
and they're more open and that's the
hopefully the world we're living in now
or people could open up and things like
that mm-hmm
better help offers licensed counselors
who specialize in issues including
depression and anxiety things I have I
can relate to as well as complicated
relationships family relationships sleep
in grief stress trauma anger you know
most people think you know I'm tough
I'll figure it out I'll do it and that
stuff just builds up and builds up and
if you have somebody to talk to I just
think it's vital and these guys are
great
you can connect privately with a
counselor through text chat phone and
video calls I mean how many counselors
can you do that with get help on your
own time at your own pace at an
affordable rate inside of you listeners
will get 10% off their first month with
discount code inside
that's better help calm slash inside why
not get help better help calm slash
inside that's great he was a good man I
see that that's all it's obvious the way
you you you should you're soakin so
passionate when you talk about him and
you know you keep him alive with your
words man there's no doubt about that
and your mom is and she's in your life
still she asked you guys are tight yeah
you probably got closer inadvertently
almost we got closer I think more than
anything was just age like she and I
didn't in some ways were just very
different people and I and I allowed
that to be I allowed that to stop me
from putting in effort because I didn't
want to get hurt sometimes like we would
fight and we we just kind of see the
world in very different ways and that
ends up causing issues that I don't deal
with in any of my friendships because I
tend to be drawn to people who are
like-minded and who I just get along
with and that said you know you always
spend time with people who see different
ways and those create amazing
conversations but when you're sitting
around kind of enjoying life you tend to
just want to be with people you can joke
around with and these and have fun it's
easy yeah
and she and I don't kind of always have
that connection but we can laugh and
have fun for sure the thing that
actually brought the closest was
the Los Angeles Clippers I started going
today yeah started going to a lot of
games and she never really watched
sports I think she did watch sports in
like college sports for her she went to
she was a wildcat in Kansas Kansas State
at Kansas State
well Kentucky Kansas Kentucky Wildcats
knows like it's the Kansas Wildcats but
it's I don't know I know there's it's
not Kay you it's Kansas day so it's
Kansas gotcha so she did like sports
then ish but I started going to clipper
game was ten years ago maybe a little
bit more and had season tickets and went
with some buddies and then she was and I
started taking her with me
it was fun yeah we just like it was like
there's this weird pressure that she
would put on our relationship that was
gone
when we went to the games where usually
our relationship was so what are you
doing well housework what's going on
with you have a girlfriend it sound like
nobody get married have kids and all
that [ __ ] evaporates and she's like so
what happened there why did why did
why'd they blow the whistle there and so
they get to present just a moment right
here this is our moment I get to explain
something to her that I know a decent
amount about I'm no expert but I get to
share with her a passion that I have and
watch her grow a passion for it herself
and it like really helped connect us in
a way weird like now I don't have a
season tickets anymore but I'm thinking
about getting back into it but it's just
such a commitment yeah 42 games whatever
I tried to do the Rams season Oh
eight games on the season to that yeah
who wants these am i doing this to
myself those you can sell anything for a
good amount of money you probably make
good money back
so now even though I don't have those
tickets we still just talk about
basketball right when I see her all
right kid let's go I gotta do I got to
do more more with with that I feel like
you know I'm definitely getting to a
place where I just don't want to fight
anymore like you said you don't have
anything in common really so but they're
all right I've just stored it I
gravitate towards let's talk about this
I know we could talk about
I talked about this and you sort of like
not to be a dick but I want the things
are always on my terms or the other
person's terms or our terms like in
other words if it's an easy friendship
you call me when you want I'll talk
there's nothing you don't even have to
talk about it but when there's certain I
don't animosity or there's things like
you know divorce parents and averey will
you know you're not to can talk about
that you're not gonna talk about mom
you're not gonna talk about Lori my
sister you're not gonna talk about this
you want to talk to me about this that's
great and we're not gonna talk about
money because lord knows I've given you
enough and we're not gonna talk about
that let's talk about you know and
sometimes it's I just do what I can and
I don't want to feel guilty like I think
I'm a good song they have a great song I
think I've done a lot but I remember in
the past I'd get really short and I'd
say some [ __ ] that I was just like what
the [ __ ] and I'd lose you know I guess I
went on the phone I say oh you are
[ __ ] spoiled why are we you know and
it would just be like why am i doing
this to myself those are the habits that
you created at 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 and
you just hold on to that so you repeat
that cycle it's not good but it's deep
[ __ ] like those are easy things to break
through yeah so good for you for for
putting in the effort to try and figure
that out I I go through the same thing
where I know how irrational there are
and I am in certain moments and I tried
to like break that down and not react
the same way because it's it's up to me
to danger she's I know at this point
she's not gonna change it absolutely not
and part of it I've realized more
recently is having boundaries up in how
yes I bring her into my life as opposed
to what I let her do she can do whatever
she wants and that can't be like you
can't having a relationship with those
kind of demands it's untenable because
you can't control another person but if
I just alter the amount of access that
she has and and bring her into the areas
in which I feel comfortable that's it
that's how that's how our relationship
can yeah yeah and that's and it's it's
actually great we do that in every
relationship in some
most in the good ones those doors don't
exists so you don't think about it as
much but there are ways in which you do
and don't access particularly Ria's of
your life with everyone do you know what
I do know before I call my mother I will
take a deep breath if I remember I
usually remember now well just that was
a little snotty you getting over cold
no oh oh okay now um you're gonna be
pleasant you're gonna be patient you
talk to yourself and annoy you but it's
go okay so you can just you know say I
love you when you get off the phone
it's gonna make it feel real good make
you feel nice and you know have a
conversation and see what she's up to
and really you know because I'm always
interested like what are you and it
always becomes about something else and
without you know comparing and through
up here you know I grew up in Indiana
but I was born in New York but um so I
do sort of this is what its gonna be
it's almost like when you're talking
you're about to talk to someone like a
producer or something let's take a
breath what are gonna talk about what do
you need to get through instead of just
getting on the phone go oh so hey I just
I kind of need to connect for a second I
just need to get my thoughts together
and just go all right listen she's gonna
bring just ask them how they're doing
show the love change the direction of
the conversation if it gets a certain
way ask how Gordon's do and I care it's
not about caring it's like I don't want
to work myself up I'm not gonna get
myself or I I almost worked myself up
just saying what I just told you talking
just now I thought about something
that's good anyway so I get it so you do
these fight you find your peace I try to
find my peace and I try to I don't want
to yell anymore I don't want to do it
you know I just say you know Mom it's
not about this all the time whatever I
learned look I'm not a [ __ ] you know
I talk about this but I you know I went
to a Wellness Center I go to therapy I
do meditation I do things I don't I
don't know anything all I can tell you
is what works for me and is what is
working for me yeah so I have helped
myself and I think help my relationship
and just become a better human being by
putting the work in
so what upsets me is when someone else
doesn't want to put the [ __ ] work in
so like hey go see someone or you know
and if they don't then I have to go okay
well I'm taking care of myself so what
can I do
to protect myself because I'm doing a
lot of work here and I deserve certain
you know whatever you know I think in
those in familiar relationships it's
harder to kind of make demands like that
but in personal relationships obviously
you you create the terms with the other
person yeah but in familial
relationships it's a lot harder you just
kind of you got to take what's valuable
from that this is and this is just me
speaking to myself I'm not telling you
and anyway what do tombs should do tell
me but but tell me but I'm trying to
take what's because she's my mother is
an incredible woman yeah
incredibly strong incredibly caring and
battling a developmental stage in her
life that was so difficult her mom was a
nun who her father convinced not to go
into the nunnery and give herself to God
and instead of marrying God marry a
human man who pales in comparison to God
which should have been Bill Cartwright
and well that's well does my mom later
but my grandmother her mother married a
human man who never like who'd could
never make her happy she wanted a
different life and gave it up for a man
who I think was incredible
my grandfather was a great dude amazing
sense of humor where was he God he
wasn't God it turns out and that was the
problem but he was he just had a great
sense of humor and huge heart great man
yeah and she was I only remember her
being miserable and that was in her
older age but I all the stories that I
heard from their childhood was that has
a huge effect I'm huge like all these
things that you fight with your mother
and/or father about whenever you talk to
him that isn't even like who you are now
it's who you were and you're sort of who
had to come to you in a way but it's
always a part of you I mean these things
that happen to you during your life and
you're you know and it's just this is
what happened this is how I fell this is
what I had as a child and you have to
get to a certain age like alright well
now I'm an adult so I could go work on
my
[ __ ] or I could just blame the [ __ ]
world yeah so you have to at some point
just go alright here's a reality this is
what we're doing I am gonna change the
way I think I'm going to work on myself
I'm not gonna blame this and but I have
people my family and I have friends that
they you know it's always about well
this my dad's a [ __ ] up and this is
this and you just have to and I have a
relationship with my mother and my
father but again it's on and I feel like
it's on my terms in a way like look at
they call me I'm gonna I'm just saying
that I'm not going to allow them to make
me feel so a certain way I'm going to
walk away from something or tell them
hey I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do this
I'm gonna hang up the phone right now
I'm not comfortable I don't like where
this is going
and I'm gonna call you having your
[ __ ] if you say something that
didn't happen if we're talking about the
past when I know it did in my eyes and
it actually happened to me
don't say it didn't you know what I mean
so don't [ __ ] with people's memories the
way they perceive things that's why I
try to talk about different things
that's those are tough things to combat
you just want someone to go I'm sorry
yeah and I just saying your parents just
own up to it
yeah onna I will own up to as much as I
possibly can
I will say just speaking for my mother
she's on dub that's one of the beautiful
things about our relationship is that
I've because I've started saying hey
look I'm I can't talk to you for a
little while you did something it hurt
me I'll talk I'll talk to you when I can
but I just needed I needed time and and
then I'll go back and revisit and she'll
say what's happening like whoom and and
it's on my terms that were meeting I'm
I'm not going to be forced to I still
love her there's that that gap doesn't
realize some sort of anger or hostility
in fact it's it's me doing what you do
on the phone which is taking a breath
and remembering that she's not doing any
of these things on purpose she didn't
want to hurt me the way that she did she
perhaps made a selfish action that's it
and the effects of which had she known
would be so severe she probably would
have made a different decision but
because in that moment she's only
thinking about herself she's making the
best decision
with what she knows and so later I can
say well here's what you did
this wasn't your intention but this is
the effect it had on me it hurt me
tremendously I still love you I want you
to know that things like that make me
recoil and I will do my best to make
sure that you don't have the opportunity
to hurt me like that again this doesn't
change that I love you I still love you
tremendously and I will still see you as
much as I can in that situation you will
not find me again and I died that's
that's honest and that's it's also
holding them accountable yeah
and holding yourself accountable for it
like talking up for you like speaking up
not just hiding behind like that's
[ __ ] I'm not gonna say anything
about it [ __ ] them and then you have all
these rows it because I think that's
what's happened to me for a long time is
it did you just get more resentful right
you just start thinking wow it's like I
can't even talk to some people about
things because their view of what
happened and I'm not crazy or completely
I really have a vivid memory of certain
things that's so pure and so honest and
so at times [ __ ] that how could they
see so far apart from me how could they
not acknowledge what I'm saying
yeah and just even if they don't see it
that way so I listen I am [ __ ] sorry
I am deeply sorry if if if you if you
felt that way if I was like that I I
wasn't aware and I was being selfish or
whatever but I but then there's some
kind of uh it's brave to do that it's
brave to own up to it and sometimes you
don't have to own up to it because
you're right
but own up to it because you might be
wrong I think that's
the important thing then maybe you're
just wrong maybe the way I was affected
by something which really hurt me and
affected me as a child that's my truth
so just respect my truth yeah and I
think that's pretty way back to Freaks
and Geeks know don't forget to go over
my resume but you know some things
happen like I read that you know after
freaks and geeks you were depressed
because about one season well I work
again you were talking about working in
the coffee industry what was it as a
barista for one day maybe five hours I
made two dollars not to brag from the
tip jar someone was nice enough to say
here take this I was in my early 20s at
this point and I just didn't feel like I
was going to work out in this business
and I didn't I think I'd lost some
passion for it too at that point because
it's sucks like the people that you it's
a business and when you meet enough of
just the business and you get [ __ ]
beat to [ __ ] by the business you're like
wait the thing that I love doesn't exist
here anymore
you really thought no one's gonna cast
your acting careers over yeah I did I
didn't I didn't really feel like it was
a place where I could thrive anymore
that I had the kind of relationships
that were valuable just because it's I
love working and I love meeting new
people and I love new experiences like
that spider-man is one that was very fun
obviously Silicon Valley and now those
have become family and and those are the
experiences that I only want that's all
I'm here for and and ending up on a show
where it isn't like that or doing doing
something that feels like business like
the only purpose that most of the people
are there with is to make money it that
isn't that isn't what I'm interested in
and that's what it kind of felt like was
only possible and that was shunning me
so I've I got really lucky
knocked up happened and then my life
shifted do you think you're grown-up
enough maybe not the term do you think
you're mature enough do you think you
have had enough life in the face that if
something happens now or you don't work
for some reason and
you just stop working for a while that
you would have that level of like I'm
not gonna fall apart
I'm not gonna get depressed I'm gonna do
what I can and figure it out never I
don't think it's possible for me I I
also what do you mean it's not
impossible to do what I I don't think
it's possible I I don't think that's how
I'm wired well even when we would shoot
Silicon Valley and I felt confident
because HBO was so I was such a
proponent of the show and was so
supportive and with us I felt always
good that we would come back season 1 2
3 like once once season 2 happened and I
was like oh great we'll run as long as
we want to as long as I can Alec are
excited about this we're rolling and
even then at the end of every season
there's just it's like going to a
wedding or a bar mitzvah or a party for
months where you like go and you see
your friends and you're like this is the
best this is the best thing that's ever
happened the weekend's over and [ __ ] do
you feel like [ __ ] and it's all over
that's how you feel and yeah you get
depressed
oh absolutely like when you talk about
depression do you talk about like it's
situational depression or is it really
like if this show doesn't come back what
am I going to do
no it's a yeah it's a situational it's
definitely not it's more just like
lashing out probably at the people
around me and and and wanting to like
sit at home and sulk a bit for a bit but
that that's something that I think fades
within a couple weeks and there's still
kind of like a lingering like just
missing don't like yeah for what that
was but now like we finished in October
so we finished on October or November
and I haven't worked sounds I've worked
on a friend's show here and there I want
to let you know something that's called
Thanksgiving in the holidays and now
it's January yeah I don't have something
like lined up I'm not are you freaking
out I am old enough now to recognize the
thing that you're getting at I think I'm
getting at it which is and I think I'm
finally in the awareness part of the
cycle currently
so that I can calm down cuz coming back
in January after the holidays I was like
[ __ ] I need a job
I need a [ __ ] job like how is that
gonna happen but don't you ever sit back
and go kind of millions of dollars now I
don't well that we are in different
situations I don't know hang on hang on
live on I looked up your net worth on
Wikipedia how's that it just says it's
it's probably not accurate Valley for
six years I mean you're not broke you
know what I'm just trying to say is this
you don't have to work right away if you
if you don't want to that is a good
thing that I have Excel of Sheree of
experience it's a great thing yes which
is not lucky thing it's an unusual thing
for me in my because it's the first time
I've been on a show for more than two
years so this is the first time you get
to a point where you renegotiate and
I'll have something sitting there after
each season it I've been without worry
to like not work in between yeah right
that's not a luxury that anyone has that
isn't independently wealthy from their
parents or something right and so to
have created that for myself is very
fortunate and I'm just enjoying this
good what it is how hard are you and
yourself do you do you get anxiety do
you are you a quick learner with wings I
always asked us to people learn it with
your lines are you someone who stresses
about performance was I good enough or
do you let things go do you watch
yourself a lot of questions here but
overall it's that feeling of just are
you really confident about things or did
you just as insecure as anybody else it
depends on Silicon Valley it was real
difficult to learn the monologues at all
man yeah those lines I teach it because
it's all foreign it's speaking French
yeah like lines like I like the sound of
you chortling on my ballsack now that
one's easy got that that was easy spoken
by a 280-pound pile of [ __ ] and is that
hard to memorize that one when I get I
didn't know you weighed that much just
jokes it was not yeah I know
the one telling you know the ones that
are difficult are like all the tech
mumbo-jumbo jargon which especially this
last season and there was one week where
I worked like usually and maybe you've
had different experiences but I can't
say in this business I've really worked
much because most of the time it's very
plush it's you know the the worst it
gets is the crunch of doing an
independent movie where you have no
money no budget and you're trying to get
a day you're trying to get your 8 9 10
pages in a day well that's the hardest
we don't have time for two or three
takes Martin Warner we got it we have to
you know we don't have time for this
because we need three or four takes for
something else later today that's more
important and and that's it's all like
scheduling stuff but this there was one
week that we were our schedule was
manipulated because of kumail had other
obligations and so his movie his
schedule was shifted and that and that
shifted our entire schedule and so
there's one day I was on three and a
half hours of sleep and that was the day
that I had the biggest [ __ ] monologue
of this season and I just had so much
trouble we terrified I know I just felt
bad I just felt unprofessional were they
upset with you no one was upset no I
liked usually the case mostly yeah if
you're mostly professional but in our
heads what it also like it was my brain
couldn't function
they say that you shouldn't drive if
you've had less than five hours sleep
four hours sleep because it's the
equivalent of being drunk and your brain
just isn't firing on all cylinders right
and they were fortunate they were we
were for it I was fortunate they sent a
car so I didn't drive that day but I had
to do other things that I couldn't do
drunk and this was one of them was say a
page and a half it was three pages I
think total with little bits that other
people were doing in between but there
were massive massive incoherent manalo
are you getting anxiety were you getting
a little tingly feeling like oh my god
oh my god I'm [ __ ] up I'm [ __ ] up
yeah for sure yeah
like nervous like this sucks I'm not an
actor
I'm not good I'm gonna get fired this is
why I shouldn't act just get me through
the scene I'm done cuz that's what goes
through my [ __ ] mind I made those
jokes I didn't feeI mean this is our
final season so I wasn't like I'm gonna
get ya but I made those jokes because
that feels that makes me feel come more
comfortable but it it was it was more I
was I just kind of felt we've all been
there just get loads just felt honestly
like Here I am
[ __ ] living yeah whatever dude I
honestly said that this to a director
because he was asking me the hardest
things that happen like I've lived a
pretty [ __ ] I have asked the director
to listen man I'm thinking about getting
an earwig your wig yeah I'd like to
because you don't see it I know Robert
Downey jr. where is one and I'd love to
just have one and someone just throw the
lines at me so I never have to worry
about lions because lines always [ __ ]
scare the [ __ ] whether they said I'd do
it okay as long as just distract
everybody else I'm gay how about you
know a cue cards uh I mean look I'm just
saying to make it easier when it's those
big days yeah where it's like you know
if you have a big monologue I could do
it twice if you just [ __ ] root you
know if I don't have to [ __ ] or you
could be a professional just I don't
have the gift like certain actresses who
or actors who've been on here
Kristen Bell there's certain actors go
yeah I can get in the [ __ ] I know you
worked with her I could learn it in the
trailer I can't [ __ ]
I mean her brain it's genius far more
gifted than mine but I think also it
helps how much she does those kinds of
things like those exercises just build
that muscle or you do it and she's
constantly working she's constantly
doing everything that she can and she's
she does music - so she's like learning
new songs and just kind of she doesn't
stop she just doesn't stop you know it's
funny as a motor that I don't envy her I
love her
yes and I think she's one of the most I
don't envy that schedule anthropic for
shiniest great motto that I'm throwing
every compliment at or all I'm saying is
I never want to work that much I don't
know how someone I don't know I don't
get it
for me I'm not in yeah I agree with you
but her talent I would sing so badly
would be the coolest thing to be able to
sing look if I could sing I have an
album
Yukie that you can sing uh-huh hey Frank
some geeks you I heard this you might
deny it that you bulked up for freaks
and geeks for something and the producer
said no so then you had at the gym
locker scenes you wore a rope I had to
wear a robe you were you upset about it
no I don't care
Franco and I were working out at the gym
at the um a lot which what was the lot
that we were at it's right across from
paramount
you know I'm talking about how I don't
think so it's been there for so long I
forget that I forgot the name of it at
the moment
you're working out with Franco Franco
and I were working out of the gym it was
a bad idea I should've been working at
it wasn't proof that it certainly wasn't
professional why was it a professional
oh cause it wasn't in character I mean
yeah you're preparing for my personal
life when my show right I was gonna have
to do things for work in shape what's
wrong with that you told me I can't get
in shape how dare you Paramount no no
they weren't I okay it was Judd I mean
it was jodan and Paul I think they were
just kinda they come to your trailer hey
Martin if I remember correctly they just
made fun of me when it happened really
they weren't like hey dropped down the
15s know and and I wore the so there's
another episode where I'm the Bionic
Woman and I have a bra on and there was
this there was part of it which I think
they cut out fully where I'm shirtless
and then you look good put all those
things are on the bra and everything on
and instead of ever showing me sure list
they just it's just me in the bra I
think so it starts there so that you
can't see as much of me being in any
sort of shape and and that helped
mitigate my muscles does that bother you
mmm no I I had nothing to it still was a
virgin for long after that really yeah
were you not a virgin what year what
year and how old were you
2012 no it was it was the spring yeah
1919 no no it was 2002 I guess I must
have been 2002 2004 so you were 22 22 22
years old I been with my girlfriend for
two months so was it a good experience
uh yeah what yeah well then she's got
used to it I was in love at some point I
was like it didn't happen yet I want to
make sure that it's meaningful and so I
waited for it to be meaningful and I was
with my girlfriend of a few months and
we ended up being together for a year
and then it didn't kind of feel right
there was something that and so we ended
up breaking up but yeah it all worked
out I use a condom at 22 but the first
time I'd did not I think she was on
control she was controlling cruisekate
yes right if I remember correctly but
you know what I actually we might have
it first okay so but yeah little Rob
anybody yeah what kind of details to you
this is fun
so look everything started happening and
we you know obviously this is you know
the part of the conversation where it
doesn't mean anything
yes of course it does but you went to
knocked up Judd started using you for
things he didn't use everybody there's
like some of the actors in that he never
used again and I've never seen right
yeah I guess that I mean the that
because it wasn't everyone from
undeclared and it wasn't everyone from
freaks and geeks that did knocked up it
was kind of like our group of friends
and I guess Jonah was in there yeah I
was just kind of like a little group of
friends all came together to be Seth's
friends in that movie and it all felt
natural and do you still you close with
Judd um could you call him up right now
go hey just it's been a while I bet if I
did call him up he would answer and we
could like grab lunch or something but I
I guess I just have never thought - I
like him I mean I said whenever I see
him and I'm incredibly grateful for the
opportunity that he's given this
fantastic and and how much care he gave
to making the set that especially Freaks
and Geeks was kind of conducive to our
growth to like protecting us and and
that was he was he really put everything
into making it the best environment for
us as young people maybe you just uh you
get lunch that goes oh yeah Martin of
course I love Marty so talented I'll put
them in the next thing
just a reminder I'm Martin Here I am I
don't have relationships like that you
don't care about that I don't think
that's that wouldn't be my motivation
for of course not motivation but it's
like hey he's a friend I've been I've
worked on movies when I want to see him
and a little reminder that I'm scared
times where I where I where I want to be
more like that like more mind
opportunistic it is the bad word that be
the bad word of it but that's not what
I'm saying that's not a bad word it
depends on the opportunities most if you
like someone you like whatever hey I
remember I called the friend he's doing
a movie and I was just like hey that's
good was there anything in that for your
buddy or Rosie I'll give a [ __ ] yeah
friend if I have a connection why
wouldn't I use it and it's up to him how
he takes that energy but and and I mean
I hear stories to here and there of
people who are in Judds world who are
incredibly talented and they should work
non-stop and for whatever reason they
don't and they they have the same
bluntness with their words and it ends
up working out that they get to be in
things that they should be in anyway
right so I see nothing wrong with that
it just isn't a world in which I feel is
it's not a way in which I feel
comfortable operating and when James and
Seth he still talked to those guys I
just saw Seth though a week ago we did
he has a pottery his three pottery
wheels at his place and what I went over
and did pottery whenever done Potter
that seems pretty cool on it if I did a
few times a soothing it's the best does
it really take your mind off life for a
minute it's meditative it's great doing
something with your hands you know what
else I did which is incredible and I
really enjoyed it
I got very into kitchen knives like
Japanese kitchen knives all kinds of
kitchen knives Japanese make the best
German steel is meant to be one of the
best Japanese Japanese knives are rather
incredible but I think those are almost
infamous because of sushi do you have a
lot of these knives at home got a lot of
knives if you had one set of knives to
say hey you should get this if you want
a really good set of steak knives and
all-around a good set of knives so it
said as I made my
kitchen knife come on star knives I
don't think that'll be a thing maybe it
will but I have thought about getting
like if I'm not working going and
focusing on something like like Seth is
making his house it's there's a giant
table full of all the pottery that
they've made his wife Lauren and and
then outside is a ton more work that's
in progress and then in their garage is
just everywhere
things like mid process and it's so much
more than you could like nobody needs
more than a few ashtrays how many rooms
you have in your house and he easily has
like 50 ashtrays and I'm sure he's got
plans to do something with them but that
I'm just like well like kitchen knives I
could make for a while but then what am
I guess are doing like at some point I'm
gonna have more kitchen knives than I'll
ever use in my lifetime then they just
become gifts and I start giving hey good
to see it Mike I brought you this knife
thank you for sure have anyone here tell
me hug past yeah yeah mmm-hmm that I
don't know but I like this I like that
I'm every stop because what do we do
Ryan on Friday night I have people come
over what do we do art night art night
fortnight I'm terrible that - all right
I'm terrible its resident you're focused
you're just like enjoying things you
have to be great is it paint is it
specific art is it paint watercolors
what no you just sort of bring a thing
you just draw whatever's a past and I
was in your heart yeah sometimes like
themes like if you want to but it
doesn't matter some people go like I
don't want to do that theme because I'm
not an artist that's one thing it's one
thing where when I do it I can just go I
don't have to be great at it I don't
think I'm just gonna do it and get lost
in it and that really helps my mind
mm-hmm it gives me a little peace and so
I started having art nights probably
about six months ago I'm the least
talented of everybody and again that's
not what it's about if I'm if I made it
out you would have a new bottom uh well
I hope so
you got it maybe you could do the Casey
emblem on our no there's actually a
dinosaur [ __ ] a robot that I'm
working on painting right now and I sort
of [ __ ] a robot so I'll bring that
over and work on is that true yeah my
buddy painted it on my wall I I needed a
real pick-me-up this is I forget why I
was depressed
but he came over to cheer me up and he
painted it a dinosaur [ __ ] a robot on
my wall they chew you up and it made me
so happy and so now I'm painting on a
tool box for him a woodworking tool I
think that should be a TV show like on
Spike TV or some a dinosaur [ __ ] a
robot
Dinobots I feel like it is that was the
show was that a show but they weren't
[ __ ] robots no you gotta party get a
lot though
oh my man all right this is from patrons
I have this patreon thing and these are
from patrons asking questions for you
quick laser like it's called [ __ ]
talking with Rosenbaum okay do you
charge them to ask you questions no and
then how patreon works now they just
join if they want to if they want to be
helped you know towards the podcast they
like it they want some behind-the-scenes
footage you want like Q&A special things
that only they get so they can do
whatever they want you don't have to
join it but they join it they love it
people love it it's really cool so [ __ ]
toggle arose oh here it is
who's Angie who's your favorite Muppet
who's the guy with the long nose enoki
oh no no the blue gonzo gonzo that's
that's a good one
that's my guns have talked hey there I
don't remember
Mike I do it's Sophie am do you have any
great stories from a set of Roswell oh
that's where I you know what no I
probably do it just takes too much to
dredge the better question is quickly
yes or no do you believe in
extraterrestrials yeah I mean we're not
the only life form in the universe do
you think they're walking around amidst
all of that I don't know you know
they're they've probably made some sort
of contact with our planet I don't know
what that means I can't like Roswell I
mean that if I had that level of
clearance I would immediately go to
Roswell just to know what's going on
Jason D which actor would make you laugh
the most in the set of knocked up but JJ
and I would Jay Baruchel and I would
drive to work together on many occasions
and we just had a hoot we had a real
hoot because he didn't have a car out
here and he's from Montreal and he just
also didn't like driving so I'd pick him
up and we drive to work together on
occasion
nice of you jerry w recently watched
intruders oh yeah which we enjoyed what
was it like to play such an intense
character fun a good departure from the
other stuff that i do i like playing a
killer i think you can do that pretty
well it was i enjoyed it yeah i could
see in your eyes that right you wanna
you know you're great at playing nerds
or [ __ ] or this but when you get to
play a lid of a deeper and do your [ __ ]
yeah there's i definitely have that i
can i feel like because what i learned
initially was improv it just it taught
me to act kind of inside out and really
just find something like tap into parts
of myself that feel authentic and
natural to whatever it is and there we
all have all of those things and i think
it helped me just maintain contact with
those so i can use them if i need them
and that was really fun to just be a
real piece of [ __ ] who is a real piece
of [ __ ] andrew see how jealous are you
of kumail's i said that right Camille
yeah Camille Camille Camille nan
Jionni's ABS be honest this is a safe
space yeah I mean I'd take some ABS if
you're handing them out good body
yeah he's put a lot of work into his
body and it's paid off Lucas it was he
who they I'm gluten-free
I'm dairy-free he was doing the Paleo is
it paleo I don't know Kinect Keith
kinesio Kido Kido he was doing the keto
diet which initially I think he put on a
fair amount of weight and muscle and
then keto just rips all the fat off
because you start using fat as an energy
source and you're not eating carbs
you're just eating proteins and fats and
things and so you the way that your body
the energy that your body consumes isn't
calories in the same it's not carbs
anymore
we all use carbs for energy you really
learned about you start using fat for
energy like your body shifts so it's
probably eating late in the morning
don't eat right away and then I think he
also does that work yeah all right Lucas
Sam are you as cynical and complex as
your characters persona in Silicon
Valley cynical yeah for sure we all got
that
yeah but you're not as much as a dick
you know what I realized when we cuz we
would do a lot of Q&A is for Silicon
Valley and I realize on that character
no well when I was myself the audience
didn't respond as well so so then if I
would just turn that up that part of the
dial up a little bit they loved reading
the audience yeah just like I was like
oh wait you don't want me you want us
all to like come up here and be our
characters and I'm like [ __ ] yeah they
don't get that my god I'd rather get a
laugh and enjoy this experience then
like share some part of my soul with
strangers who don't really care Matthew
Jay what are your favorite guilfoyle
invoked joke from Silicon Valley if you
had to pick my favorite has to be the
let blame die chart
oh that is a good one I think the dick
joke is goes down all time was one of
one of the one of the most fun ones what
was it again we're all just [ __ ] yeah
like how fast could you jerk off a whole
room full of dudes and then Kumail and I
actually went and presented at like the
smart people Awards I forget where I
forget what it was actually called but
it was like geniuses like actual
scientific is yes she'd like just people
who were changing the planet changing
the way that we live here and we were
giving an award we were we were like
going up and and we were going over our
speech or like our back and forth Kumail
and I on our on our way up on the flight
to San Francisco and we're like let's
let's just scrap all this and we'll
improvise a thing where we do the dick
joke but like in this room how long
would it take for us to do to jack off
everyone in this room it didn't go over
very well but it was so fun to watch
that joke bomb it was so rewarding you
didn't get nervous at all yeah not
really like once you're up there no one
else is funny you're at a smart people
convention the emphasis isn't humor
right so it makes sense that it also
makes sense that it bombed Lisa last
three questions favorite memory from
freaks and geeks said it's just too many
I mean I lose your favorite like the one
person you just grabbed it
it's a guy just I just want to be around
this guy John and I are close Seth and I
ended up living together after the show
was done and we get we were very close
Jason and I were close for a bit and now
it's been so long I don't I don't I
think Linda is easily the person that
everyone just kind of gravitates she's
amazing I love Linda she just has such a
huge heart
uh-huh and as Jays she was she always
felt like a older sister and and it's
such an incredible comforting sweet
caring way she's great
Angelina gee what direction do you think
or would have liked to see Freaks and
Geeks go had it taken that had been able
to continue and that's hard this is a
question from Angelina Jolie Angelina
Jolie Wow well Angie I mean that's a
hard one much well they had already
talked about it and so why don't you go
look that up Angie yeah is your reason
Jelena Jelena they talked about me being
a sports like a sports guy like going
into like our the Geek Squad separating
because I was working out like actually
working behind the scenes they're like
oh we'll put him into like he'll become
an athlete and like not get why he's now
disconnected from his geek but he's like
why they've turned on him and he'll be
accepted into the jock group and it'll
and it'll like just I think that was the
shift that they were going to make
season - I feel really fun and you could
have worked out it would have been crazy
right
it really would have been a weird turn -
except I think in some ways that
character bill was a heart like a such a
deeply heartfelt part of the geek
stories so to like lose that like what
it changes such a huge dynamic I don't
know how you would really do that and
keep good because you have these guys
like you're like they're on the side
sort of like going can't believe it like
this even know who he is he's gonna come
back begging us to be your friend again
I mean what is he doing these people
don't care about him they don't it's
that whole dynamic you know I think
that's what it would have been and then
you know said one day you wake up and
season three now you're back with the
geeks ya really missed you guys what
happened while I was gone I don't know
you got big and stupid
glass one Mary B what kind of advice do
you have for the actual freaks and geeks
of the world just be true to you and the
world will catch up yeah and especially
nowadays I think geeks and they're
they're cooler they you know you got it
but it's it's also like your raw like
the things that make you a geek are the
things that make you great yeah that's
my take on well dude this has been
fantastic it was deep I hope you had fun
Jeff fun yeah Yeah right it was great
catching up with it it was man last time
we hung out I think you you played a
football with us yeah I came out and you
had like actual like college football
guys who dominated you played well I did
not you're athletic yeah I could throw
the ball a little bit but every like
everyone there was like real athletes
like oh we played a one-nothing
whatever whatever a one refers to I
don't know but did you get hurt
no did you have fun yeah yeah really
nice yeah what's your Instagram handle
all that jazz no just my name just
Martin Starr with two R's yep right
Martin Starr start as long as we're
talking well am i hey man thank you for
allowing me to be inside you this is a
real treat I really had fun I'm glad you
came in you ended it all like that huh
thanks for letting me be inside you
usually yeah that's your big ending that
was a throwaway that time though wasn't
gonna let you throw that one away yeah
listen I want you to come in ronal
mcdonald house with me sometime
absolutely and I want to hang out with
you again I want to say I'll see ya the
microphones are done I thought about
good I'm glad thanks for rubbing so
honest because I with people out there
you wouldn't think it but they you've
probably helped someone out there just
but the relationship with your family
and losing your father and all these
things that make us human and we have to
deal with in life and it really it's
nice to see you just open up and tell
your story so absolutely all right man
thank you
Martin's just a good guy he was open he
just talked about things and I was like
you know sometimes most time I feel
pretty comfortable but he made me feel
really comfortable there's there's times
we feel you just ask someone anything
because if I really think he knew the
show whereas like maybe he didn't listen
to it all the time or even listening to
it but he knows that it's helping people
and they know that you know people are
getting something out of it so if he
shares a story somebody out there is
listening going I can relate to that and
that's what it's all about have your
parents listen to it they have they
hated it
they just as Christ you're laughing no
because the way I told him listen to
because I realized it was the Joe the
truly oh one but I forgot for the first
10 minutes you talked about
colonoscopies and now they enjoy it
there they let you think I've to lie to
me neat over the truth they didn't enjoy
the [ __ ] part they were to the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] they were turned off by
that my mom has a mug I gave that she
that she has that at work the one that
says yeah great we got tons of shirts
and mugs left I got left on Laurel [ __ ]
here and big shout out to my patrons
here we go you know who you are I love
these guys and by the way if you join
patreon it's helping the show it's like
you've whatever it is a little something
and people always say I'm sorry I can
only give five dollars or a dollar
but I just you guys subscribing on
YouTube and on the platform just
subscribing to the show is enough this
is just icing that just sort of you know
helps cuz we're not like that you know
we're growing well we're going yeah so
here are the patrons top tier patrons
Alison Andrew Angelina Barry Bob Bob
we'd never last name for one of those
Bob's Bob and Bob or attacks
Chris Dion Emily and Emily Jason Jason
Jerry Jill Trisha you Kiko
Kevin Kristen Lauren Lee mark Michael
Nancy Nico ROG Robert Samantha Sarah
Scott Sean Tiana
thank you guys I mean top tiers I mean
just given your your uh I don't know
what to say sometimes I just text you
and say thank you so much oh my god
you're so kind and like of course we
love the love it again if you love the
podcast subscribe on YouTube and
subscribe on all the platforms if you
want to listen on the way a work it
really
helps hit that notification bell so you
notified spread the word and that's it
tomorrow night stage it with me and the
boys left on Laurel I'll go to stage at
7:00 p.m. I'll be in Mexico this weekend
and remember Austin Texas March 31st I'm
interviewing Zach Levi at the north door
first show sold out but they're still
tickets for the second one check out my
Twitter Instagram you'll find it also
Zach posted it it's gonna be fantastic
you know camp Rosie's around the corner
so look for that I'm gonna read a little
fan letter because I always like to read
fan letters this is from Chris from
Orlando Michael I admit late to the
party I didn't know you even had a
podcast until Stephen Amell tweeted
about his recent experience with having
to return to finish an episode with you
being a huge fan of arrow and Smallville
I figured there was no way I'd be
disappointed after listening to two
episodes I was hooked
you're by far my favorite talk show host
my talk show host now you are well how
about an actor writer and podcast guy
this is a talk show and you're the host
of it thank you
hmm I don't know how you cracked the
code I can only assume the lack of
cameras and your demeanor bring out the
vulnerability in people although Chris
now we have cameras but we're still
getting people to open up I'm now
listening to everything from the
beginning you're making people I've
never thought twice about into
compelling and complex individuals that
I'm eager to learn about thank you for
showing what podcast really can be if
they are given the proper care and
respect keep up the great work you've
got another dedicated fan that will
happily spread the word Chris Orlando
Florida that's awesome that is really
awesome you know I think I think that's
really nice to hear when people are like
and then they listen and they're like
you know I like and they just support it
and you're doing something right I
definitely feel like I'm doing something
right I mean we're doing something right
Here I am
I think so we're not trying to just be
funny we're not trying to be we're just
talking to people yeah not hurting
anyone no I don't think we're hurting
anymore I mean some interviews I'm sure
I hurt people's ears guys I can't thank
you enough for your your loyalty Ryan
Ryan's working very hard in the video
he's getting it down give him some love
show up even say Ryan great job on the
editing or Ryan you made a mistake
love that favorite love hearing that
thank you so much for allowing me to be
inside of each and every one of you
until next week if you're not inside
you're outside hi guys we'll see you
[Music]